even though Richard sunak was avoiding
reporters questions yesterday on the way
to France on this very issue didn't want
to get involved but I suppose that isn't
really a sustainable position for the
Prime Minister since Mr lineker's
comments were about his own policy and
it doesn't seem sustainable when we are
talking about the public debate the
public interest in this whole Saga
getting to such a level that the
corporation is really in crisis it's a
long statement even though Mr sunite
doesn't seem to take a clear side on it
this is what the Prime Minister has said
as PM I have to do what I believe is
right respecting that not everyone will
always agree that is why I have been
unequivocal in my approach to stopping
the boats Gary lineker was a great
footballer and is a talented presenter I
hope that the current situation between
Gary lineker and the BBC can be resolved
in a timely manner but is rightly a
matter for them not the government what
that process is ongoing it is important
that we maintain perspective but
particularly given the seriousness of
the issue at hand forty five thousand
people cross the channel illegally last
year many of whom have been exploited or
trafficked by criminal gangs putting
their lives in danger we need Richard
student access to break this cycle of
misery once and for all and the policy
we set out this week I believe aims to
do just that it is not only the fair and
a moral thing to do it is also the
compassionate thing to do he ends by
saying there are no easy answers to
solving this problem but I believe
leadership is about taking the tough
decisions to fix problems I know not
everyone will always agree but I do
believe this is fair and right of course
Gary lineker and his comparison with a
1930s Germany comparing some of the
rhetoric used by government ministers
was about what zuela braveman had said
she'd use the word Invasion a few months
ago richtunack has consistently used
much softer language you see words again
fairness and compassion uh popping up
there trying to frame this this whole
story and this policy contextualize it
in a different way certainly though
people across the country are aware of
the policy and Labor's position is is
slightly different labor have been
critical of Tim davia are backing Gary
lineker even though they were critical
of the conservative uh present of the uh
of the TV presenter earlier uh in the
week I think what this means for Tim
Davey though is is probably the the key
question at the moment the director
general of the BBC the boss of the BBC
put put in partiality as his Central
Mission uh now that is being a
criticized from many different sides and
it looks like he will have to try and
solve this thing with the TV presenter
it is a bit of a standoff no sign yet
Nick of a resolution here